like brothers and sisters i walked into
this beautiful masjid here
the orlan park masjid that looks has a
dome on the outside we're looking to
host an event here and i met this
wonderful brother introduce yourself
salaam alaikum everyone my name is
i've been a big fan of the the dean show
for a long time now
um it helped me out on a on a journey to
find my religion to
to become stronger and might not find my
religion but to strengthen my religion
to
help people that were you know kind of
struggling
with with their religion and to
basically strengthen why islam is the
truth why the other religions aren't
true
um and it just helped me interact with
society a little bit more it helped me
grow myself my confidence in my religion
and why islam was the greatest religion
ever why it's the truth and how i can
approach people knowing that confidence
knowing that allah is the true god
knowing that nothing else no idols no no
creation of allah stands a chance
against the the ideology of islam and
what muhammad sallallahu alaihi has come
to do and share and seeing those videos
that people have shared through their
journeys of you know going from
christianity to islam going from atheism
to islam and watching the teen show
helped me out a lot and into that i'm
very thankful i know it was it was a
time of covet when this happened to me
it was a time where
life was very dark you know we went and
we were in isolation
um and it just you know everything
seemed very negative and and
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah helped me
see a lot of optimism in the world
because you know everything you know the
prophet saw them says you know
is good and alhamdulillah helped me see
the good in that because i was able to
isolate myself from the world and from
the the the troubles of this world of
school of work and all that
to focus on my team to focus on helping
other people and you know strengthening
my email to strengthening other people's
iman to helping other people become
better muslim to helping my brothers my
sisters you know and then expanding that
on to communities insha'allah
very nice that was very motivating
inshallah this could be a motivation for
others also hopefully we'll see you at
the at the event this is going to be at
the local community of orland um in the
neighboring areas over here the greater
chicagoland
please if you can
make your efforts i know this this this
program has helped me and it's helped a
lot of people i can speak for a lot of
people
um you know just just finding finding
the truth because
it's hard being in the west and and
having that strong e-man having that
confidence being able to go into society
and and and and strength and having that
strong iman having that you know i'm not
ashamed of my iman as a matter of fact i
want to spread this to the world i want
more people to see why i'm so happy i
want people to know what the truth is
[Music]
allah
[Music]
alaikum brothers and sisters i am so
excited we have an event coming up we
got sheikh uthman even farooq we got dr
kareem abu zaid and other speakers we're
going to do a live show where in orland
park
here with this wonderful community
make sure you're there you can see the
beautiful dome over here it's coming up
this sunday
august 28th i want to see all of you
there come out and support we're having
a benefit dinner i'll see you in orland
park inshallah
we're getting ready for the event
sunday this sunday the 28th
here's the event
and i got the man himself who's going to
be
responsible for the food
introduce yourself
all right so make sure
you guys are there
we're going to have some wonderful food
what kind of food are we going to have
shay the best kebabs
yes
yeah
when they say but what they don't know
everybody knows bellagi huh right make
sure you guys are there
[Music]
we've been told that they're out to kill
us all assalamualaikum brothers and
sisters we went to the streets to ask
americans about islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about islam
no do you know anything about islam
no sadly do you know anything about
islam
not really do you know anything about
islam
no i'm sorry you know what islam means
islam uh
no we've been told that they're out to
kill us all
that's what you've been told
that muslims are out to kill you all
well that's what i say on tv
anything
i know it's in the middle east isn't it
well that you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many americans who don't
know about islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean's
center the first mega dawa center in
america we have five hundred thousand
dollars left and we need your help to
finish click to donate right now may god
almighty allah reward all of you